he should have been preparing for his
first match at the australian open but
instead novak djokovic is back in
detention and awaiting another court
hearing
the judge is sitting on the weekend as
the tournament starts on monday the
world number one wants to know if he can
play the australian government
determined to make an example of him
in the world's most locked down country
there is little sympathy for the serb i
feel like djokovic's case is just like a
massive flap in the face especially
after spending
so much time in lockdown he's a good
player i have nothing against him but um
i think if he did get let in it kind of
sends a bad message i feel as best as if
djokovic should probably set out this
one
this is the second attempt to revoke
novak djokovic's visa the immigration
minister suggesting he poses a health
risk because he is a high-profile
unvaccinated sports star in a court
statement alex hawke said i consider
that mr djokovic's ongoing presence in
australia may lead to an increase in
anti-vaccination sentiment generated in
the australian community potentially
leading to an increase in civil unrest
other players say the focus should
return to the tournament australian open
is much more important than than any
player so if he's playing finally
okay if he's not playing
australian open will be a great
abstraction open
with or without him
i feel
that it has taken away a little bit from
the great tennis that's been happening
over this summer in australia it is a
saga that has rumbled on he entered the
country under a medical exemption having
previously contracted covet he was
detained then released after an appeal
before being detained again
clearly the government's worried that if
mr djokovic becomes the focus of uh
dissenting opinion then that might be
likely to play out adversely generally
so
the minister has to exercise these
powers but he's also got to do it in a
way which is reasonable he arrived with
his site set on the history books
seeking a record 21st grand slam
but refusing to take the jab has locked
him in a different kind of contest
the clock is ticking and novak djokovic
still doesn't know if he will be
defending his title or taking a flight
back home shinki marike sky news